let's go to Dante from Florida we
haven't heard from Dante from Florida in
the New Year Dante what's going on hey
David how's it going good how are you
I'm good
so all right I wanted to ask you if you
came to your conclusion to write Costa
gathered off too early and I have a list
of things that she's accomplished or
things that she's done since she
announced the candidacy that should
probably make you reconsider okay all
right so recently she's been the only
candidate to say anything about Julian
Assange's arrest and she's been forceful
about it Bernie Sanders still or he
seems to have said anything about it she
clarified probably main criticisms that
people on the left half of her like her
connection to Prime Minister Modi in
India or her past positions on LGBT
community she's also she's also pushed
some of her domestic policy agendas that
people don't really talk about here like
her election reform bill that would
mandate paper ballots in all districts
or some form of paper record in order to
verify the votes which is very important
okay um she yeah she's unequivocal on
Medicare for all unlike every other
candidate except for Bernie Sanders
because even Elizabeth Warren she's sort
of try to put out some of the corporate
Democratic alternative to Medicare for
all like Medicare buy-in or lower the
lowering the eligibility age and like
things like that or having an employer
by an employer system similar to that
private health insurance system that we
have now where your employer can give
you a medicare-for-all plan so even if
elizabeth warren's equivocating on it
but costa-gavras
cosas gabbert has been clear on her
position and also her foreign policy
anti regime change and all those things
so do you think you came to your
conclusion to write her off a little too
early no I don't think so
you still there Dante oh yeah listen I
don't think I did and right now III have
to admit this may be the wrong thing to
do but there is this group of 20 20
candidates who seem unable to get beyond
1% their polling between 0 & 1 percent
and maybe this is the wrong thing for me
to do but I'm paying less and less
attention to them because as we get into
late April May and then June if you're
stuck at 1% and you've been running for
a while as Tulsi has it just doesn't
seem like you're really gonna be a
factor and that may change but I don't
know if you see those numbers any
differently yeah but Bernie Sanders
which he started in in the primary at
this point he wasn't even at 1% I'm sure
he hadn't been running nearly as long at
this point in time in 2016 you know
anything but even ok so three months
into his announcement you think he
wasn't passed what 5% or you would be
impressed well that's a birdhouse right
yeah but you couldn't look at like 60
percent 70 percent 80 percent likelihood
or polling in the in winning the
Democratic nominee so I don't really
think that's a good standard to write
somebody off for that's totally fair
Dontae when do you think Tulsi needs to
get to at least like four percent for
her to be viable um
I believe she's gonna get in the debates
in the first debate in June she's going
to put on a show and she's going to do
laps around almost everyone on stage
with the exception of Bernie Sanders
possibly okay and I think she's going to
get a big boost in and also their way
more debates than they were last last
primary so I believe she's gonna have a
chance to get her message out there and
she's gonna be very convincing because
in all of the interviews and the town
halls and public speeches that she's
done since she's now she's been very
clear and articulate and she's gotten
her point across and the voters seem to
like liked her a lot
and why doesn't she get past one percent
you know the polling is by you
don't my tonight number one all right
Dante we go five minutes number one all
right we will see you may be right I may
be eating crow Dante great to hear from
you very much appreciate it we will take
a quick break and be back right after
this